aquí tenemos un bloque estacionario que
es empujado contra esta pared que tiene
fricción con esta fuerza de magnitud efe
la dirección de esta fuerza forma un
ángulo theta con la horizontal lo que
quiero que hagamos aquí es construir un
diagrama de cuerpo libre para este
bloque así que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de hacer este diagrama por su
cuenta incluyendo los componentes
vertical y horizontal de esta fuerza eje
y otros elementos involucrados aquí como
la fuerza de gravedad y la fuerza de
fricción que actúan sobre este bloque
así como la fuerza normal que actúa de
la pared al bloque vamos a resolverlo
juntos antes de dibujar el diagrama de
cuerpo libre vamos a descomponer este
vector fuerza en sus elementos vertical
y horizontal
el componente vertical luce así y el
componente horizontal se ve así cuál es
la magnitud del componente vertical este
lado está opuesto al ángulo theta así
que la magnitud del componente vertical
es f por seno de teta esto ya lo hemos
visto en vídeos anteriores y viene
directamente de la trigonometría si por
alguna razón esto no les parece familiar
os invito a que vea los vídeos que
tenemos al respecto en khan academy la
magnitud del componente horizontal es f
por seno del ángulo teta ya que este
lado es adyacente al ángulo soca toda
con esta información ya podemos dibujar
el diagrama de cuerpo libre dibujamos el
bloque ya que nos vamos a enfocar por
completo en él ya sabemos un par de las
cosas que están sucediendo aquí tenemos
una fuerza horizontal que es f coseno de
teta que va a la derecha tenemos una
fuerza vertical que es fs no detecta que
va hacia arriba ahora vamos a analizar
estas fuerzas de aquí tenemos la fuerza
de gravedad que actúa hacia abajo por lo
que la dibujamos así y tiene una
magnitud f subjefe aquí no le dibujó la
flecha arriba porque estamos hablando de
la magnitud del vector en cambio aquí
arriba nos referimos a todo el vector y
que hay de la fuerza de fricción vamos a
suponer que tenemos una situación donde
la magnitud del componente vertical de
la fuerza f
fs no detecta es menor que la fuerza de
gravedad
la situación si no hubiera fricción el
bloque comenzaría a acelerarse hacia
abajo ya que tendríamos una fuerza neta
hacia abajo aún no hablamos de las
fuerzas que actúan horizontalmente pero
como mencionamos al principio este
bloque es estacionario no se mueve y la
fuerza de fricción se opone al
movimiento por lo que en esta situación
la fuerza de fricción actuará hacia
arriba dibujamos esta fuerza cuya
magnitud es f sub
efe finalmente analicemos la fuerza
normal si este bloque no se está
acelerando en alguna dirección significa
que la fuerza normal está equilibrando
perfectamente al componente horizontal
de la fuerza de eje que va a la derecha
la fuerza normal va a la izquierda y su
magnitud es f sub n con esto hemos
dibujado un diagrama de cuerpo libre
para este ejemplo si estas dos fuerzas
fueran iguales no existiría una fuerza
de fricción no habría nada que
contrarrestar ya que estas dos fuerzas
se equilibrarían perfectamente entre sí
y si la magnitud del componente vertical
de la fuerza f fuera mayor que la fuerza
de gravedad
y si no hubiera fricción este bloque se
aceleraría hacia arriba si hubiera
fricción ésta actuaría en dirección
contraria a ese movimiento pero vamos a
continuar con este escenario que
dibujamos acá para que podamos apreciar
la utilidad de los diagramas de cuerpo
libre con esto podemos escribir
ecuaciones que relacionen estas fuerzas
por ejemplo si este bloque no se está
moviendo para nada quiere decir que no
hay una fuerza neta en la dirección
vertical ni en la dirección horizontal
podemos afirmar que jesús n equilibra
perfectamente a efe coseno de teta
efe vm es igual a efe coseno de teta
también podemos decir que fs no de teta
más la fuerza de fricción que es f sub f
contrarrestan por completo a la fuerza
de gravedad así que esto es igual a efe
surge una vez que establecemos este tipo
de ecuaciones si conocemos algunas de
estas variables entonces podemos conocer
las otras variables lo cual es muy útil
en física con esto terminamos y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo